foreign
[Music]
the paper is about the massive discovery
of Novel RNA viruses in what we call
Meta transcriptomic data in simpler
language meta transcriptomic data is
simply the sequences of all are RNA
molecules that can be isolated from a
particular environment
in this way you get an unbiased sample
of the diversity of
viruses
um and this really
opens up a perspective that was
completely unavailable before you
discover many novel groups of viruses
that have not been seen by anyone before
simply because the hosts are unknown and
have not been grown and the laboratory
accordingly before the development of
this new type of methodology there was
simply no way to see them
we're very concerned here about that at
nlm about the purity of the sequence
samples that we get in and I wondered if
you're are you able to find the level of
Purity that you need to understand these
different Pathways Purity is not a
simple concept
Purity with respect to what or the baby
work here
is in a sense conservative
or because we have
a certain
[Music]
signature certain tags okay
or that we know are associated with this
type of viruses and we detect those as
best we can
so we try to combine
High specificity
with high sensitivity but if something
is
absolutely novel somehow unrelated to
anything that has been known
until now or then we would miss it
other approaches are necessary and in
this case the issue of Purity and
conversely contamination
um very large
the departures that we have used at
least in this particular project I don't
think so I think a rate of false
positives is very close to zero now this
particular article in cell introduced
the idea that there's more diversity and
there's also more similarity so how do
you balance diversity and similarity you
said there's more than we had expected
but also some same similar patterns that
we hadn't expected there is consider
much more diversity or than than we
expected
um at the same time
in previous analysis
on a considerably smaller scale
um we have
I believe uh established it or overall
structure or or this
part of the world of viruses of this
part of the biosphere if you will
um I haven't identified
the large division so-called Firework
and however huge uh the newly discovered
diversity is most of it does fall into
those previously established major
divisions so there is this
well I would say rather satisfying
interplay
within the already established uh course
structure and the newly discovered
diversity I want to close by
congratulating you on your election to
the National Academy of Medicine this
year I was quite proud to have another
member of our nlm staff become
recognized so widely for critical
contributions and I congratulate you
personally thank you so much it's an
certain certainly a great honor